what is going on everybody and welcome
to the generative python transformer or
gpit video uh in this video i'm going to
be running through the latest gpit
model and since the last time we spoke
github actually released
copilot and the concept of transformers
writing python code has now entered the
public sphere in a pretty large way
i think it's great all these questions
and concerns that that we have
and i think to address them we have to
do research and to do research we kind
of need access to the model and
historically
the company who calls themselves open ai
doesn't tend to
release the actual full-sized models so
my guess is we will never see the
full-size
copilot model and even like the gpt3
model is released but you
query like you don't actually get the
model as far as i understand it so
anyway and it's paid so so so yeah not
the most ideal research environment um
so anyway this model is completely free
you can use it and indeed it is really
only for educational and research use i
would not recommend you use this for any
other means
um so to use it i have put it up on
hugging face which is a popular
transformers models hub i suppose
um i have put it up in it is in both pi
torch
and tensorflow so whichever one you use
you can continue to use
um other than that let's check the
config real quick we can see that
um main things are like right here we
have a context length of 1024
so how much data can we pass as context
and then also get back from the model
the embedding size 768 the attention
heads is 12 and the number of layers is
12. so it kind of matches
i believe the small gpt-3 as well as the
small
gpt-2 i don't think there's actually any
difference um someone let me know below
if there's an actual difference but i
don't think there is
um i think that's about all i really
want to point out there
other than take note that i i believe
that
github copilot is probably the full-size
gpt-3 model so this model is 125 million
trainable parameters the gpt-3 full
model is a 175
billion trainable parameters so
a similar structure in terms of being
transformers
um but not similar in any way to size i
it's just literally impossible for me to
train
a model of that size even this model i
trained on the 150 000
dgx station a100 from nvidia um
i only was able to get like two epochs
and i can't remember how much cumulative
time that took but it took a good amount
of time
so uh keep that in mind
so to use the model uh we come back to
the model card and essentially it's just
these three lines here
i'm going to be running through my i
have a write-up that i posted on
pythonprogram.net i will link it in the
description
so i'm going to be just basically taking
the examples from here and just kind of
showing you
what this model is capable of i think
it's actually
pretty impressive it's probably not
co-pilot impressive but
it's a model that you can actually play
with right now um
and actually see how everything is
working and there's probably things that
this model can do that i'm not even
aware of yet
so just recently i became aware of like
the few shot learning so i tried some
few shot learning stuff and i was like
oh my gosh even that works like
so there's a lot of stuff that i'm kind
of surprised um
so anyways let's get to it so uh
to begin again i'm just gonna be copying
and pasting
from the write-up you can you can follow
along if you want again you if you
are on a if you're on a cpu you would
just need to remove the two cuda stuff
and it'll just be a little slower but
you could totally follow along on a cpu
and it should be fine
um so this is just a simple generate
function that i wrote
um all that it does is replace the input
newline characters with the newline
token
um and then
um otherwise yeah it's just taking the
response it just takes the number one
response you could you can tinker with
that if you want
um otherwise just just leave it that's
like the most likely to be
correct response um and yeah and then it
just returns it
we'll end up creating a few more helper
functions along the way just to kind of
show you guys and i imagine
some of you guys could probably come up
with even better ones that i'm coming up
with
but we can start by just simply
generating you know we're just going to
pass
import the text import so that's all the
model sees it's just
import and what does it return to us
we will see if this is your first time
running it you will first download the
model
when you run these two lines so it might
take you a little longer than me
initially
but anyways all we did was pass import
this was the input import
it decided that we were going to import
numpy as mp import pi test pandas pd and
then import all this stuff from pandas
and then start to make this test data
frame thing
so pretty cool and again you have a
context length that is a max of 1024 so
um and that's 1024 including the input
that you pass to the model
uh so we can we have plenty of headroom
we can make this max length uh bigger if
we wanted
oops actually we probably should have
passed that here
i think the default price should be 100
we'll just pass import
uh max length
500 there let me run that one more time
okay so now we can see okay there's a
little more information here
and again we get to this and it starts
trying to throw in these pads and so the
model is definitely getting a little
confused although this is still looking
pretty decent code here
but at least here right we can take this
copy that we'll just come down to a new
cell and
oh no module name pi test so we don't
have pi test um
but that would just be a pip install but
anyways the rest of this is
syntactically correct
this is acceptable code so
the three years ago when i last kind of
played with sequence to sequence models
trying to generate python
code it was just a struggle to get it to
be syntactically correct because
so much is going on here right you that
i think we might be taking for granted
at this point like things advance so
fast with machine learning that
what was once really cool and impressive
is like no longer really people don't
care the bar's been raised
um but even here we have class it
it properly cases the class
okay then we get to after the colon
it goes new it learns to do a new line
it learns the white space indentation
it learned so it learned not only the
pep 8 naming for
classes it learned the pep 8 naming for
methods and functions
it understands that this is a method
therefore we pass self here
right again colon new line further tab
over
that um that's really cool
to me that it's learned this uh the
comment probably
this might even match something almost
perfectly in github
again only use this for um
research and educational purposes and in
fact let's go back to the model card
and read the considerations this model
is intended for educational and research
use only
don't even trust the model outputs
they're not unique
it's not yours the model is highly
likely to regurgitate code exactly as
you saw it
so it's up to you to determine licensing
if you intend to actually use this
generated code
the python code was pulled blindly from
github so it could be a mix of python
two and three among other differences
such as tabs being two spaces or four
although personally i've seen no
instance i don't think is
two-space indentation maybe at the end
i'll
try a two-space indentation example and
see if it continues to
to follow that structure if that's what
it's seen so far
um and then finally along with the all
the above the code generated could wind
up
doing anything it could try to dos some
website it could try to delete your home
directory
okay so don't run the code right
so again research and development only
don't it's just
no don't use it for anything else so
anyway continuing on
so maybe this is like a github issue or
something i'm not sure
so yeah so pretty cool uh that we that
it's at least able to do this but i
assure you it does even cooler stuff
so uh coming back over so now let's talk
about
some of like the autocomplete
capabilities of the model so i'm just
going to
come down here paste we'll run this
so in this case we're importing
matplotlib.pyplot splt we're passing
some x and y data and we're just saying
okay do what you want from here
so we come down here and we see okay the
next thing it does is it creates a
figure and then goes ahead
and makes a plot so we can actually take
this also it comments
the x next to the y which is
interesting um but we'll copy it we'll
paste it it's valid code
and sure enough we do get the graph
right so it at least
understood okay you're starting to do
some matplotlib stuff you're probably
going to make a figure you're probably
going to want to make a plot
it does do some of this repetition stuff
we will address repetition
um soon uh but at the end of the day
what did it do it created code for us i
think i just think it's so cool
and the other thing that i'm curious
about just live what if i
add the new line before we pass it okay
so if we add the new line before we pass
it it doesn't bother with the figure
and it just goes straight to the plot
which is still acceptable code by the
way
um so that's interesting i wonder why it
did the
why why would it do the comment and like
that's why i think it would be really
cool
to be able to do r d truly on the model
um so again this is why i kind of
dislike what open ai has been doing
lately
these are interesting questions why did
it choose that
rather than um just go you know why did
it add that comment that's weird
right it's just interesting um
so anyways continuing on continuing on
we don't have to
talk about open ai or closed ai all day
uh so the next thing
is what if we have that exact same data
and rather than a regular
um a regular plot we're like no no we
want a scatter plot
so we actually just the only change that
we're adding here is we're just saying
okay add a comment that says scatter
plot
okay so we go ahead and run that
and we get again there's some repetition
we'll talk about it
but we could at least take this
copy paste and we get a scatter plot
like it again it's valid code and we
kind of nudged it to say hey
could you give us a scatter plot instead
and again we might want to change the
colors right like later you might change
that to green
um the label is i'm not really sure why
we don't even need a label but if you
want one you can have one or you could
just remove
you could remove this entirely whoops
i didn't mean to do that
right so you can do something like that
and again
it's just cool that it understood the
context leading up to this point and
then it's like oh you want a scatter
plot okay
here's a scatter plot and i think what's
neat
is you know you might like we did you
might want to change some stuff and
that's why i think
copilot is what a great name for
something like this because
that is exactly what it is like your it
gives you some output is it going to be
perfect no
you might want to make some tweaks but
it saves you it could save you time
right and i think it's pretty neat so
continuing along
uh with the commenting what if we
said we're going to come out the comment
out the y
and we just say histogram
what's it give us so again it does some
repetition but we'll just copy and paste
what we want
copy paste and again all we did was we
passed up to the comment histogram all
of this
was it just made it itself like maybe
you forgot like some of the parameters
to histogram
so we run this we actually don't need
the show
but whatever
no labels to put in the legend true that
uh
anyway uh we get a histogram
and we get a title and a y label i
that's so cool to me
i just think it's so cool it's so
exciting didn't see that this this can
work
so again um one of the other things that
is kind of interesting is the concept of
like few shot learning
so we can kind of pass in we can say hey
the library that we use for graphing
is matplotlib um and in fact matplotlib
i'm gonna say dot pi plot as plt like
that's pretty much always the right
import we could
we could try both i'll leave that one
and then we can remove it anyway
um web requests we are going to import
requests
for array math what do we do g pi t
and we can run that copy come down here
paste and obviously the hope is import
numpy import numpy as
and sure enough we get um import
and then it continues to make uh
that's funny uh that's funny indeed
plot the graph what if we do what if we
just do graphing
import matplotlib will it go
will it go uh
no it just continues graphing okay but
it does
it does do at least as plt anyway what
we we
in this case all we were interested in
was the very next line so
one of the other helper functions i came
up with
was to add this so just do
next line only and now if we and all it
does basically is it counts how many new
lines existed in the input and then it
just goes to the very next new line
that's it
so then if we do next line only based on
the input oops we didn't run that cell
we see okay for array math we do numpy
so again i that is so cool to me
that's just so cool to me um so another
option that we have
is like for example um
array math uh we could say uh what do i
do neural networks
neural networks what does it do it says
from keras
dot layers we import dense dropout
flatten
and it really wants to flatten so one
more flattened right
that's so cool that's just so cool um
what if we
it won't always work so what if we do
deep learning
we can kind of try a few deep learning
wants to import matplotlib
no surprise machine learning
whoops
right so it's definitely not always
going to work
um
let's see yeah web development
websockets i wouldn't recommend it but
possible
um how about make a website
yes absolutely correct it also require
imports requests twice but that's okay
um okay so
again that's really cool yes it doesn't
always work i would be very curious to
know like
um what was it let's try deep learning
um yeah i would be curious again
or in for just r d and educational
purposes
what happened there right it's
interesting
it's an interesting question so um okay
so continuing
so continuing with the flask
idea if we paste this in uh let's say
we start to build a website we say okay
from flask we're gonna import
flask render template we're obviously
trying to make an index page a home page
what does it do
and what it does is it creates at least
after this which is basically up to this
point
it says okay define your index return
render template index.html with methods
get method only so again
accurate that's exactly what we wanted
and we couldn't in this case we couldn't
do just
next line because it would just say
define index um
so we just went ahead and generated
everything but then we also
noticed that it does do this kind of
like repetition stuff still um
so those would still be something you'd
want to logically handle for at some
point
so for example we can throw in
this function so at this point if we
split everything
up and we see that the line is identical
to a previously seen line
as long as it's not just a simply a new
line um
then we don't want to see it again so it
and then we've reached the end
essentially if we see a repetition so
uh so for example if we take
this copy we come down here we paste
and next line oh that's not what i
wanted
uh generate let's see did that actually
so like at least the index here
uh we would want so let's do
stop at repeat
who do this cool so at least
that by this point it sees oh you're
about to define an index again
and it at least stops at that point it
might be it'd be enter this one is also
incorrect right because we've already
handled for index
i can't think of a really quick and easy
logic way to handle for that
um but again as your as your co-pilot it
definitely saved you time writing and
writing all this uh so at this point you
could just delete that or
you know do whatever to handle that so
next
we'll try some good old-fashioned deep
learning i took this from my
my deep learning tutorial um and
actually this isn't in
it but the question is okay you pass all
of this information
can we hint so first off we could just
start by doing this
and just see what it does um
cool
so it starts off by take you know just
saying hey we're going to start with a
dense layer 256
units with an activation of rectified
linear which okay that's fine it doesn't
actually know at this point what are x
and y
the only hint might be the com2d or
maybe psyphar or something like that but
um yeah so that's the next line that it
thought
would be useful to add what if we don't
want that though we want a conv layer
so what if we just come up here and we
say um
like i just said yeah conv we can try
other spellings because again
there it gets a little finicky sometimes
conv
so here it says okay we'll do a conv
layer we're going to add a comp 2d
64 units then we're going to do max
pooling
okay and again this is taken from my uh
tutorial here so it's possible some of
this code was on github
already anyways and maybe that's why
where it got the
it's interesting that it defaulted and
wanted to do dents 256.
kind of curious about that instead of
doing the going straight to the conf but
one thing we are missing is an
activation
so what if for example let's do
conv i don't know let's try conflair
okay convlayer
with relu activation
give us the activation i demand it
um interesting we really want an
activation
here but no matter what it wants to see
seemingly do this convlair um
128 features
i'm just curious nope
we tried we tried um okay so convlair
let's just continue on we don't
um i still want i wish there was a good
way to slap in the activation here but
whatever
we'll we'll tinker with that maybe in a
moment so
then i'm just gonna follow what i have
uh written already for now uh let's say
we wanted to do a flatten
again we're still missing these
activation functions which is a bummer
so then it knows okay model add
flattened easy enough
and then finally what if
you're like okay now i want output 10
classes
i just think that's so cool um
one thing i don't remember if i tested
this so i'm gonna say output five
classes
not quite buddy at least it threw in an
activation function though
i put two classes
tank it wow that's crazy that it knows
output 10 classes
but none of the others
huh another time
i saw that um
i did i just can't remember the exact
pattern that i did to get it but i did
like
i did uh flatten like i did flatten
comment like this
and not only did it add the flatten it
did a new line new line
comment space capital d dense
uh and then it added the dense layer i
just
i had to walk away for a second i just
thought it was so cool
again i recognize again we're missing
the activation here
um it's not perfect it really isn't
um but it is
it's so cool to me and it's again a
huge huge improvement over what we had
three years ago
actually i want to do this um so then
finally
what if we add optimizer
going a little bit off of script here
i'm just curious
sad oh the mac it might be a max length
issue hold on let's do
this but then also let's see would it be
a max length issue
should be fine it just seems like it's
more than um
optimizer uh model
compile see if any of these work
sad um what if we do
just this let's get rid of that like
other
messy info
really
maybe it's trying to throw in some other
uh
[Music]
it gets pretty funny i'm sorry um okay
so not the best not the best
like i said research and educational use
only
so uh finally we have some pie torch
we can definitely give pie torch a
little bit of love
so we'll paste in some general pie torch
code
so essentially we've defined our neural
net also can we just
i mean this is why i hate pytorch
it's like so much code is required to do
like this
right you got to come down here and you
got to do this
it's so ugly anyway
so for the forward method it does the
flatten here and then it does the relu
uh does it twice i'm not actually sure
what that's going to cause but
essentially you would really just need
to delete this and you'd be good
then it goes to define the neural
network again which is kind of weird
but actually this is very close to being
accurate and again
for writing pi torch code i like pytorch
because you can do some really cool
custom stuff with it
easier than you can often do it in
tensorflow
but gosh it's such a pain writing
everything that you need to write so
this would be a perfect example why you
would want to have um
you know something like this to to help
you but
anyway i think that's good enough for
now uh like i said the model is there
for you guys to play with just
at least for what i have personally
found it does some pretty good
next line auto complete it can do some
pretty good next
few line autocomplete uh and then it can
also do some very interesting
few shot learning stuff that i'm just
starting to figure out like how to
how to do like an inference pattern and
get it to
to figure out what i want and to just
continue going so it works really well i
think with the imports
it would be interesting to see it work
with maybe one liner functions
stuff like that so definitely a lot of
room for research development definitely
a lot of room for
questions as far as how to use these
things going forward and what do we do
with this technology
uh going forward but we really can't
answer those questions without having a
model to actually test and do r d
on so i hope that people will use this
for that purpose
um and and again i just will remind
please
just don't use this for anything else
it can really it can put out it can
output like anything
so um just be careful like it's purely
for
educational research use only um but let
me know what you find i feel like every
time i sit down and kind of just tinker
with this model for like
20 30 minutes i learn a new thing like
the last thing was the kind of
just trying to play around with the few
shot learning and i was
really surprised like the you know use
doing few shot learning kind of in the
methods that most people do with
language like did not work and then i
was like what if he just used comments
to like hint
like here's a comment do this thing
here's a comment do this thing so
without fine-tuning it to
like i thought you would have to
fine-tune it to do that um
and i still think you could take this
model and you could fine-tune it for
exactly that like you could fine-tune a
doc string to a function
um completely possible haven't tried it
yet but
i'm fairly confident that's going to
work especially after i've seen
doing the uh the comment to code or
comment to import at least works and
then comment to some code works like we
saw with like some of the comments with
um
you know the layers of a neural network
and so on that kind of that kind of
works it'd be interesting to see how big
of a scope
can we get that few shot learning to to
work on
but definitely i haven't really done any
fine tuning of this model so this is
just the base model
yes there's some cool stuff that we can
do right out of the gate but it'd be
interesting to see
what more it can be done so hopefully
some people can do some
really cool and interesting things with
us and help us to answer some of these
really pressing questions that we have
um especially now that copilot
is out and on the way
like like things are about to change i
think uh pretty considerably so
um very interesting stuff hopefully you
guys enjoyed
leave your comments questions concerns
whatever you know feel free to leave
them down below
otherwise i will see you guys in another
video
you